so we have a lot of screenwriters that
watch the YouTube channel yeah and they
have screenplays that they want of
course made into movies obviously now
your latest film is all I want yeah okay
so now this is the second script that
you've produced in the last was it four
years um in the last I guess four or
four or four or five years or so
okay so then did you sell either or both
screenplays in the process of getting
them made I mean
well this this film here all I want is a
little different from someone I used to
know which is my first feature in a
sense that I was approached by my
producing partner
Melissa center who's also our lead
actress and she had an idea for a story
that she wanted to dig at and then
scratch at and see if it was worth
bringing to the screen and so she
approached me and I was working on
another project at the time and so I was
brought on to really help her mold the
story and help her kind of figure out
what is the most interesting kind of
narrative and during the process of
developing that story with her I became
more and more involved with I guess the
the the bones and the skin and the
skeleton of the story and during the
process we both became really really
kind of connected to the story to the
vision and then that's that's when we
decided like let's go and and try to
make this thing happen so I went away
and wrote the script and then we raised
the money and and and you know did the
casting and all that stuff so this is a
little different in the sense that the
story was not an original idea from the
very beginning of me you know in my head
as opposed to my first feature it was an
idea that I was who was swimming in my
head for a long time and I wanted to
sort of get it out
so this has been a you know
collaborative process with with another
person but the process of writing the
story at the end of the day is still
very similar you know you're still
trying to figure out plot points and
pacing and character and
and length and budget and all that stuff
so a couple questions come up for me
one of which first off is financing how
did you raise the money we know we did
the traditional route we went to a
studio and they said no no kidding no no
we went to we did crowdsourcing you know
the the first approach was really we
went to IndieGoGo and we raised a lot of
our initial kind of you know budget
through that and then at the same time
during the campaign Melissa and I were
reaching out to people on the side who
might be interested in coming on board
as a executive producer who could
potentially invest in a little bit more
time or money to help us you know bring
this vision to life so it was a
combination of kind of private
investments and and also IndieGoGo
campaign so did you know a lot of your
contributors so the IndieGoGo campaign I
have to say and this is the amazing
thing about my producing partner Melissa
you know she's really really great her
talent is really kind of like winning
hearts and minds you know really
she's very engaging as a personality
she's very smart she's very astute and
she went out there and just really
really made a lot of connections to
people and I would say you know we had
people contributing anywhere from $5 to
a lot more than that and either very few
of them were strangers I would say a lot
of them you know were personally
connected to her people who really were
allies of her and then the rest of them
were either friends of mine or friends
of the cast or friends of you know the
production but you know it's it's if you
look at our thank you you know it is a
long list of thank-yous and that's
because we had a lot of people kind of
donating their time
donating their money and you know this
movie would not be worth is now without
them so do you mind if I ask how much
you raised with IndieGoGo how much did
we raise we raised I think 11 thousand
you know or 11 or 15 I can't remember I
mean it's it's on the web if you guys
have shown that and I we did it over 45
days I believe and and and I would say
probably half of them Melissa and I did
personal you know video thank-yous to
because we wanted to really kind of you
know reach out and and and and and show
our gratitude so you know a lot of
people came and supported that so great
my second question is how did you know
that working with Melissa would be a fit
because from what you're telling me it
sounds like you guys have a great
working relationship and that you
clicked but people don't always click
and it's through no fault of their own
it's just but how did you know when you
first met her that it was gonna be it
was going to be someone that you
probably could work with for a while you
know I did I didn't know I didn't know
and that's an interesting question
because I've had a lot of that kind of
discussions you know those kinds of
conversations with different people I
have friends who I've known for a long
time and we don't really mesh creatively
or whatever you know I think in the
beginning when she approached me having
gone through my own indie production
having written plays and produced plays
and directed plays and short films I
kind of like I could see the big
mountain in front of her that was kind
of possibly in her blind spot and she
came to me full of kind of ambition and
it was so pure and and you know she was
very enthusiastic and I knew that she
was gonna get a lot of nose and for some
strange reason and I told her this story
for some strange reason I didn't want to
be the person saying no to her because I
was like you know she's gonna get so
many nose so I just kind of said yes I
said I said she was like are you
interested in having meeting with me to
talk about some ideas that I have
some project I don't know exactly what
it is yet but potentially looking for
someone to help me write this thing and
so I was like yeah you know I'm a fan of
her as an actor you know we met as
actors and and so I was like yeah and
then it was basically just all along the
way again she has a talent of really
winning hearts and minds and I think you
know at the end of every session you
know she would go away and and like when
are we meeting again and I was like okay
you know Tuesday or you know Friday and
that kind of kept going on and on I just
kept on you know kind of saying yes to
her thinking that this is gonna be such
a impossible task you know and it
suddenly became just this kind of animal
of itself you know and then we we both
kind of like started to believe in it
and then we were both really kind of
going out and winning hearts and minds
together and then to answer your
question about the compatibility I think
I think there's a unique kind of yin
yang between she and I because she's
great at the things that I'm not great
at she's really great at I don't know
what part of the brain she's really
great at prioritizing you know having
some idea of how to take care of the
bigger picture in small bites and she's
really great at making sure that I stick
to a certain schedule making you know
just really kind of allowing me to kind
of like giving me that I guess giving me
the boundaries you know because I was
really out there trying to like suggest
this in that and she was like what about
this what about that so I think I think
we play different kind of notes on the
keyboard you know and I think that's
nice you know sometimes you work with
someone and then you're both kind of in
the same kind of like area you know and
and and so and I think that you start
competing in terms of approach
so I think along the way when we were
working together it was great because we
weren't really able to delegate well
you're better at doing this so you do
that and I'm better at doing this so you
do that so so yeah
you